>> Pete: THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME WE APPRECIATE IT?
>> THANK YOU.
>> Pete: WE WILL CIRCLE BACK
TO PREVIOUS SEGMENT.
HOPEFULLY YOU STUCK WITH US
ABOUT WHETHER CALIFORNIA
SHOULD SUCCEED FROM THE
UNION.
JOINING US NOW VIA SKYPE.
WE HOPE THE CONNECTION IS
SOLID IS MARCUS LOUISE EVANS
THE PRESIDENT OF YES
CALIFORNIA.
THE GROUP ADVOCATING FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE.
I WILL POSIT OUT LAST THING
I DID UNHAPPY WITH STANDARD
OF STATE AND STANDARD OF
LIVING U WHATEVER IT IS,
CONSERVATIVES AND I WANTS
FROM US STRAFTED WITH THE
POEM OF CALIFORNIA.
IS THE AT THIS POINT WE WANT
OUT?
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT IS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND FOR
AMERICANS U REUTERS DID A
POLL IN JANUARY OF 2017.
IT SHOWED 47.5.
47.5% IN CALIFORNIA WERE
NOT, QUOTE, NOT OPPOSED TO
HAVING A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE SESSION.
32% WERE FOR IT, LARGER
PERCENT SAID LET'S DO IT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.